مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
[موسيقى]
نفاع هل يتحمل المدرب الايطالي روبرتو
مانشيني خروج او مسؤوليه خروج السعوديه من
كاس اسيا من الدور ال 16 شوف امبارح سمعت
بعض المحللين عم يحكوا ويقولوا انه
مانشيني بتصريحاته قبل البطوله اثار
البلبله وعمل ازمه داخل المنتخب السعودي
وهذا الامر اللي اثر سلبا على حمله
السعوديه بكاس اسيا ولكن بحقيقه الامر اذا
بنطلع على الموضوع وبنرجع بالزمن شوي لورا
بنعرف انه المحللين وال والاعلاميين
والجماهير السعوديه كانت عم تطالب من شيني
بتوضيح لاستبعاد نواف العقيدي غلط من شيني
كان بالاسلوب لانه لما طلع يحكي عن قضيه
نواف العقيدي حكى عن سلمان الفرج وحكى عن
سلطان الغنام وكشف تفاصيل كثيره هذا اللي
شعل الازمه بالسعوديه وانا بتفق مع
الجماهير والاعلاميين اللي انتقدوا منشين
على هذا
التصرف الازمه هي بالتاكيد اثرت على حمله
السعوديه بكاس اسيا اثرت سلبا بكل تاكيد
ولكن هل هي السبب او هل هي المشكله تعالوا
نروح لمشوار السعوديه بالبطوله مشوار
السعوديه بالبطوله بكل امانه كان مشوار
جيد جدا والمنتخب السعودي كان عم قدم اداء
معقول وحتى امام كوريا بمباراه كوريا
الاخيره المنتخب السعودي قدم اداء جيد
ولحد الدقيقه تقريبا 75 المنتخب السعودي
كان متفوق تكتيكيا على كوريا ولكن مشكله
مانشيني لما سجل هدف ما بادر ما حاول
يستحوذ على الكره ويحرم الكوريين من الكره
ما حاول انه يجازف شوي اكثر ويحاول يسجل
بالمرمى الكوري حتى تبديلاته الهجوميه مثل
تبديل عبد الرحمن غريب مثلا اجا بالدقيقه
484 وبالتالي هذا الامر عطى اريحيه اكبر
للمنتخب الكوري عطاه حر حريه اكبر انه
يشكل عليك ضغط من الدقيقه 75 لحد الدقيقه
99 بالمباراه هذا الضغط اللي ولد بالنهايه
هدف كان متوقع انه يولد هدف لانه ببساطه
لما تحط الكره مع خصمك او تعطيل الكره
وتستسلم بدفاع ورا وتحاول انك بس تتجنب
الهدف فمن الطبيعي انه الهدف يجي فيك لانه
بالنهايه بده يصير في غلطه غلطه تمركز
غلطه مدافع بالاضافه طبعا لانه المخزون
البد للمنتخب السعودي ولاعبي المنتخب
السعودي قل بشكل كبير باخر دقائق وهذا امر
كان
واضح اليوم ممكن منشين نفسه يجادل ويقول
والله يعني لاعبين الوسط الموجودين عند
المنتخب السعودي اقل جوده من لاعبين الوسط
الموجودين عند المنتخب الكوري وهذا امر
حقيقي وصحيح لانه شفنا حتى خلال الشوط
الاول بالربع ساعه الثانيه من الشوط الاول
كان المنتخب الكوري عامل ضغط عالي على
السعوديه والمنتخب السعودي واجه مشاكل
كبيره بعمليه الخروج بالكره بهي الربع
ساعه لا لانه ما عنده اللاعب القادر انه
يخرجه من مناطقه تحت الضغط ولكن بوجود
لاعب مثل فيصل الغامدي ما نزل امبارح كان
ممكن يتم هذا الامر ويكون الوضع افضل
بالنسبه لوسط المنتخب السعودي ولكن
الاعتماد على على الخيبري وكنو وناصر
الدوسري اثبت انه المنتخب السعودي لما
يكون تحت ضغط ما بيعرف يطلع بالكره بينما
المنتخب الكوري عنده لاعبين وسط كان يلعب
تقريبا بخمسه اثنين ثلاثه لاعبين الوسط
اللي عنده كانوا قادرين
تحت الضغط السعو بكل سهه يعني ما كان في
عنده اي مشكل بالموضوع هذا يحس لمنشي طبعا
ادال رديف بين الشوطين ويحسب لميني عم
ولكن خلينا نروح للقطه الاهم في المباراه
اللقطه اثارت كثير من الجدل واللي راح
ها قص وروايات وحكايات لانها بصراحه هي
شغله نادره بعالم ك القدم نادرا ما انك
تشوف مدرب عم يغادر الملعب قبل نهايه
المباراه او قبل نهايه الركلات الترجيحيه
مانشيني امبارح لما عبد الرحمن غريب ضيع
الركله الثانيه للسعوديه كانوا الكوريين
رايحين يسددوا الركله الاخيره اذا سجلوها
فازوا اذا ضيعوها الامل موجود مانشيني قبل
تسديد هذه الركله حمل حاله وغادر ارضيه
الملعب الى غرف تبديل الملابس هذا التصرف
اللي اغضب السعوديين برروا مانشيني وقال
انه هو كان مفكر انه المباراه خلصت وما
قصد انه يسبب اي اهانه او قله احترام لاي
احد ولكن بعد ذلك طلع ب مقابله مع ابو ظبي
الرياضيه وقال انه انا شفت انه باقي ركله
يعني فقلت خلص خالصه المباراه وحملت حالي
ومشيت هذا التصرف غير مبرر وهذا التصرف في
الكثير من يعني التخلي عن اللاعبين
اللاعبين اللي دافعوا عن مانشيني في ازمه
اللاعبين الثلاثه اللي كانت قبل البطوله
اللاعبين اللي وقفوا مع مانشيني اللي
قاتلوا مع مانشيني لاخر لحظه انك تتخلى
عنهم بهي الطريقه فهذا امر غير مقبول غير
غير مقبول للجمهور السعودي حتى انك باي
شكل من الاشكال تتخلى عن الفريق وتحمل
حالك وتمشي قبل نهايه المباراه هذا امر في
تقليل من احترام الجمهور وفي تقليل من
احترام حتى المهنه اللي عم تشتغلها يا من
شيني طيب الان بعيدا عن هذا التصرف شو
الحلول هل لازم مانشيني يستمر ولا لازم
يمشي بصراحه انا مش مقتنع بنظريه المؤامره
في بعض المحللين كانوا عم بيحكوا امبارح
انه منشين عم يتصرف بهي الطريقه حتى يحكوا
له بالمنتخب بالاتحاد السعودي الله معك
ويعطوك الشرط الجزائي ويحمل حاله ويمشي
ولكن انا مش مقتنع بنظريات المؤامره لانه
هو لو ما كان مقتنع بالمشروع ما كان اجا
اساسا هو عارف التفاصيل كلها يعني ولكن
اللي واجهه مانشيني مع المنتخب السعودي هو
مشكلتين اول مشكله انه اللاعبين غير
معتدين على طريقه ال 3 خ ا لاعب السعودي
يعني اعتقد مرات قليله بيلعب بهي الخطه ب
مع المنتخب لذلك في بعض اللاعبين ابرزهم
مثلا سالم الدوسري على سبيل المثال ظلمته
هي الخطه لانه سالم الدوسري غير معتاد انه
يرجع لنص الملعب يستلم كره ويطلع فيها و
ويبدا الهجمه وغير معتاد انه يلعب دائما
بالعمق كمهاجم ثاني ما يلاقي مساحه
المساحات امامه تكون ضيقه وغير قادر على
انه يتعامل مع الكثافه العدديه للاعبي
الخصم بعمق الملعب وانه ينعطى ادوار
تكتيكيه دفاعيه ايضا فوق ذلك سالم الدوسري
بحب المساحه بحب يلعب على الجناح بحب يكون
بالواحد على واحد ويسجل هدف وبالتالي سالم
انظلم في كثير من اللاعبين الاخرين ظلموا
ايضا بهذه الخطه ولكن هذا اسلوب منشين
ولكل مدرب اسلوب وكان لازم الاتحاد
السعودي هو ينتبه لهي الجزئيه قبل ما
يتعاقد مع مانشيني المشكله الثانيه اللي
عم واجهها مانشيني انه اللاعبين اللي
موجودين بمنتخب السعوديه حاليا مش عم
ليلعبوا اساسيين وهذا امر طبعا الكل حكى
فيه والكل عارفه والكل بيعرف انه موضوع
استقطاب النجوم اثر بشكل كبير على اللاعب
السعودي ولكن
هون لازم يكون في استراتيجيه عند الانديه
مش بالضروره الاتحاد السعودي او رابطه
المحترفين تفرض قيود على الانديه السعوديه
بحيث انه يصير مثلا في اربع محترفين بس مش
ع او خمس محترفين لا ممكن الانديه نفسها
لما بدها تجيب لعيبه تجيبها على اساس
الحاجه لهؤلاء اللاعبين يعني اذا عندي
لاعب سعودي مميز بمركز الجناح مثلا ما
بروح بجيب نجم كبير بحطه جناح وبحط اللاعب
السعودي على الاحتياط لا خلص هذا اللاعب
السعودي قادر يعطيني لاب جيد عم بدي منيح
بخليه حافظ على مركزه وبدعم مركز ثاني
ممكن يكون اقل من هذا المركز بلاعب نجم
ولكن لما بنعرف انه المشروع بالسعوديه مش
بس مشروع رياضي هو مشروع اكبر من ذلك بعرف
انه بعض الانديه اعتمدت على شراء الاسماء
المتوفره بالسوق حاليا وانه يجيبوها لحتى
يستخبوا جماهير ويطلعوا مصاري من وراء
الموضوع لذلك لا الوم من شيني فنيا ولكن
الوم من شيني على السلوك وهون بنجاوب على
سؤال هل يجب ان يستمر ولا لا على المستوى
الفني مانشيني يجب ان يستمر لانه شوي شوي
راح يطور اللاعب السعودي راح يطور فكر
اللاعب السعودي را يعطي تنوع بالافكار
اكثر للاعب السعودي ولكن مشكله مانشيني هي
بالسلوك والشخصيه وهي مش بس مشكله مانشيني
مع المنتخب السعودي بالمناسبه هي مشكلته
مع مانشستر سيتي مشكلته مع المنتخب
الايطالي مشكلته مع كل الفرق تقريبا اللي
اللي دربها لانه مانشيني شخصيه قويه جدا
فيها الكثير من استفزاز احيانا للاعلاميين
وحتى للاعبين وهو صارم لدرجه احيانا بتكون
مزعجه للاعب وهذا الامر بخلي اللاعبين
بعاد عنه وبخلي في حاجز بينهم وبينه على
عكس ايرفي رينار اللي كان مدرب السعوديه
بكاس العالم 2022 بالنهايه هذا القرار
يعود للاتحاد السعودي نحن بنحلل بنحاول
نطلع بافكار نطلع بحلول ولكن الحل الامثل
بالنسبه للسعوديه انه يجي مدرب قريب من
اللاعبين فاهم عقليه اللاعب السعودي وقادر
يتعامل مع ال السعودي في الاستحقاقات
الكبرى ان كانت قاريه او حتى بالمونديال
او بتصفيات كاس العالم هذا كان كل شيء
بحلقه لون بعد الصافره حتى نلتقي الاسبوع
المقبل كونوا بالف
خير